[Music]
this is a song
that evokes
a feeling
of counter cultural revery
it is a song
of rebellion it is a song that
encapsulates the 1960s
that movement towards liberation that
casting aside of rules and regulations
that casting aside of socialization the
1960s were so romantic because they
represented a time of dissolving of
power structures and dissolving of
patterns of thought it was a time of
revolution it was a time of social
upheaval it was a time of sex drugs and
rock and roll it was a time where
collective effervescence was common you
joined your compatriots in protest
against systems of repression it was
like les miserables but in the 1960s do
you hear the people sing singing the
songs of angry men it is a music of a
people who will not be slaves again this
was a time for revolution this was a
time for transformation this was a time
for
transmutation
this was a time
where our reality tunnels gave way to
new possibilities a time when we were
struck by starlight and the birth of
possibility when baseline reality
dissolved and no new realities emerged
in its pixelating wake the field of
possibility
filled the space
everything was possible sex drugs rock
and roll revolution peace and love and
technicolor dreamscapes
that's
a revolution
that's a revolution
and then friends
and then
well
nothing was ever the same was it
a rabble rousing and scallywagging
opened us up in ways we never thought
possible it was a fever dream
a psychedelic fever dream and everything
was alive with a kind of heightened
qualitative intensity it was a taste of
freedom all our mental models gave way
to rhapsody and rapture we were free we
were free
[Music]
revolution
revolution
this was a revolution
of the mind
cut